I turn first to our decisions on tax
I have tried to be fair by following two
broad principles firstly we ask those
with more to contribute more and
secondly we avoid the tax Rises that
damage growth
although my decisions today do lead to a
substantial tax increase we have not
raised headline rates of Taxation and
tax as a percentage of GDP will increase
by just one percent over the next five
years
I start with personal taxes
asking more from those who have more
means that the first difficult decision
I take on tax is to reduce the Threshold
at which the 45p rate becomes payable
from 150 000 pounds to 125 140 pounds
those earning 150 000 pounds or more
will pay just over 1200 pounds more in
tax every year
we're also taking difficult decisions on
tax-free allowances
by maintaining at current levels the
income tax personal allowance higher
rate threshold main National Insurance
thresholds and the inheritance tax
thresholds for a further two years
taking us to April 2028
even after that
we'll still have the most generous set
of tax-free allowances of any G7 country
I'm also reforming allowances on
unearned income the dividend allowance
will be cut from two thousand pounds to
one thousand pounds next year and then
to 500 pounds from April 24. the annual
exempt amount for capital gains tax will
be cut from twelve thousand three
hundred pounds to six thousand pounds
next year and then three thousand pounds
from April 24. these changes still leave
us with more generous allowances than
countries like Germany Ireland France
and Canada
because the obr forecast half of all new
vehicles will be electric by 2025 to
make our motoring tax system fairer I've
decided that from then electric vehicles
will no longer be exempt from vehicle
excise duty company car tax rates will
remain lower for electric vehicles and
I've listened to Industry bodies and
will limit rate increases to one
percentage point a year for three years
from 2025.
the obr expects housing activity to slow
over the next two years
so the stamp Duty Cuts announced in the
mini budget will remain in place but
only until the 31st of March 2025 after
that I will sunset the measure creating
an incentive to support the housing
market and the jobs associated with it
by boosting transaction During the
period the economy most needed
I now turn to business taxes
while I've decided to freeze the
employer's next threshold until April
2028 we will retain the employment
allowance at its new higher level of 5
000 pounds this means 40 percent of all
businesses will pay no Nicks at all but
that threshold is already more than
twice as high as the EU and oecd
averages I will maintain it at that
level until March 26th
my right honorable friend the Prime
Minister successfully negotiated a
landmark International tax deal to make
sure multinational corporations
including big tech companies pay the
right tax in the countries they operate
I will Implement these reforms making
sure the UK gets our fair share
alongside further measures to tackle tax
avoidance and evasion this will raise an
additional 2.8 billion pounds by 2728
I've also heard concerning reports of
abuse and fraud in r d tax relief for
smes
so I've decided today to cut the
deduction rate for the SME scheme to 86
and the credit rate to 10 but increase
the rate of the separate r d expenditure
credit from 13 to 20 despite raising
revenue the obr have confirmed that
these measures have no detrimental
impact on the level of r d investment in
the economy
ahead of the next budget we'll work with
industry to understand what further
support r d intensive smes may require
next windfall taxes
I have no objection to windfall taxes if
[Applause]
in Energy prices but but
I know the honor worm was obviously
getting excited at the talk of windfall
taxes can I just say that any such tax
should be temporary not to deter
investment and recognize the cyclical
nature of energy businesses so taking
account of this
I've decided that from January the 1st
until March 28 we will increase the
energy profits Levy from 25 to 35
percent the structure of our energy
Market also creates windfall profits for
low carbon electricity generation so
from January the 1st we've decided to
introduce a new temporary 45 levy on
electricity generators together these
measures raise 14 billion pounds next
year finally finally I turn to business
rates
it's an important principle that bills
should accurately reflect Market values
so we'll proceed with the revaluation of
business properties from April 23 but I
will soften the blow on businesses with
a nearly 14 billion pounds tax cut over
the next five years nearly two-thirds of
properties will not pay a penny more
next year and thousands of pubs
restaurants and small High Street shops
will benefit this will include a new
government-funded transitional relief
scheme as call for by the CBI the
British retail Consortium the Federation
of small businesses and others
benefiting around 700 000 businesses